so what will our currency be 500 years
from now I like to think that we might
be space tourists right and space travel
is going well and what will we use as
currency in space well you know if we do
a transaction in space the distances are
quite far so if you're on one planet and
I'm on another planet we do a
transaction considering the theory of
relativity like how do you calculate
interest rates and when time is relative
what do you put that clock to calculate
interest rates you would have to build
arguably a distributed network
throughout the galaxy right so that when
you're doing the transactions you could
basically be calling on information
systems throughout different moons and
different planets it may be that we have
to have a find a new rare metal to use
as a currency like what are the use of
star wars they use something called the
intergalactic banking unit or the credit
and that was based on a rare metal so it
might be that as we start to see space
tours and tourism we have to use some
kind of new metals that we find the
galaxy we might have had to build a
distributed network throughout the
galaxy so we can verify local
transactions and even here in America or
in the world in the earth we might be
building systems or it's like an energy
grid we're all plugged into the same
grid and we're trading vitamin B and
calories and we are rebalancing our
energy because if you look throughout
the natural world energy is the currency
of the natural world the further we get
into the future maybe money may remain
the same and remain remain as energy
it's not so crazy to look at science
fiction and in fact the first time the
credit card was ever mentioned was in a
book in 1887 called looking backwards by
a man named Edward Bellamy it's about
this guy who falls asleep wakes up in
the year 2000 and what does he see he
sees the government creating credit
cards for their citizens and the
government issues money on these credit
cards and so on or with socialist utopia
but if you look to the future you can
look at what economists say about the
future but I like to think about what
are the science fiction people saying
about the future what is the idea of
money in the future and so some science
fiction writers say well maybe in the
future if you can have a pacemaker
embedded into your body why not a
payment device right so you just wave
your hand over a payment reader what
about a reputation ship where you walk
in to a store and everyone knows your
epic
already I mean that already happens I
walked into a store that are a
restaurant the other day and someone
check out my cell phone because the
maitre d said you know I'm sorry I don't
have a reservation and I took out my
cell phone and I was just texting my
friend you can take your time and the
maitre d said well sorry sir like please
don't write a negative review of me on
Yelp or on Google s I'm not gonna do
that
but to him his reputation was a currency
if I put a negative review on him on
Yelp or at the Internet
I might be intruding I might be damaging
his future business in that case we
don't need a brain chip for a reputation
reputation is already a currency